es geht um corona und da hören wir
erstmal augenscheinlich eine gute
nachricht gesundheitsminister sparen
will die epidemische notlagen nicht über
den winter hinaus verlängern hört sich
erst mal gut an die scheinbar gute
nachricht vom gesundheitsministerien
sparen nämlich dass so ein bisschen das
zeichen corona vorbei sei die ist auch
noch nicht überall angekommen zumindest
nicht im ganzen land und man hat das
gefühl viele macht corona immer noch
kyra und irre denn wenn wir sehen was in
hessen und niedersachsen gerade passiert
im supermarkt zweig wenn wir erleben was
im theatern und museen in düsseldorf
passiert auch da nur zwei gehe dann
fragt man sich haben die dem
gesundheitsminister nicht zugehört
glauben die den experten nicht warum
befinden die sich immer noch in dieser
corona wahnsinns lage und man hat so ein
bisschen das gefühl sie wollen gar nicht
davon los lassen ja sie wollen nicht
dass dieser zustand irgendwie vorbei
geht sondern sie bewegen sich immer in
ganz kleinen schritten und immer mit den
warnungen und mahnungen der vergangenen
monate und man muss ja eins sagen viele
dieser mahnung dies sind gegeben hat vor
einem halben jahr es wird wieder ganz
schlimme im winter es wird ganz
dramatisch und vielleicht gibt's wieder
lockt all das hat sich eben nicht
bestätigt wir sind jetzt im herbst wir
sind sozusagen in der saison wo ist dann
eigentlich wieder los gehen müsste und
wir erleben keine vollen intensivstation
wir erleben keine
zahlen die nach oben gehen aber was wir
erleben im alltag ist ein crooner
wahnsinn weitergeht ich weiß nicht ob du
mal im hotel war es zum beispiel und
siehst wenn du da um es buffet laufen
muss mit einem pfeil dann eine weile in
verschiedene richtungen und dann auch
auf die toilette in verschiedene
richtungen alles schön brav getrennt
voneinander alles muss brav getrennt
bleiben und sie glauben ja tatsächlich
dass das irgendwas bringen könnte ja
menschen sind fast religiös überzeugt
davon dass diese maßnahmen ihn am ende
vielleicht noch das leben rettet und
wenn wir uns anschauen dass in manchen
kneipen man schon angst hat nuss boxen
hin zu stellen weil verschiedene
menschen dort reingreifen kanten könnten
dann merkt man dass corona dieses land
und viele menschen sehr verändert hat
ich finde man müsste viel mehr das
machen was ihnen spaß gemacht hat über
das ende sprechen ist ist vorbei wobei
diese nuss boxen ganz ehrlich sagen ich
fand ich vorher schon eklig auf
vorverkauf
ist eine andere da sie eine persönliche
entscheidung wenn man aber wegen corona
sozusagen die jetzt verband und ich
denke dass jetzt endlich schluss sein
muss und es muss auch schluss sein dann
mit der diskriminierung einzelner und es
darf nicht sein dass dann zum beispiel
wie in düsseldorf passiert plötzlich in
theatern und museen menschen ja menden
diskriminiert werden wenn man sagt da
gibt es nur zwei gegner reicht auch kein
test mehr nein diese zahl geben das
nicht mehr her
[Musik]